wenn sie sich anschauen
doch war er bis zum team
was ich hinten und innen hier
individuelle geschichte wissen wie ich
aber mal so ein bisschen die zeit nach
england schauen um europa was fehlt ist
gut gesellschaft wird
und das wasser generation und jetzt wird
wieder gesprochen industrie 40 lassen
würde ihn ist der revolution
und wenn man anschauen welche aufgabe
hat bildung das industrielle herz und
geist
manchmal habe ich das gefühl dass auch
die schulen rein schauen da hat sich
seit der letzten
wenn es richtig diesen tag ein bisschen
besser vielleicht nicht ganz so
vielleicht in der art unterrichtet wird
bei den bildungsmedien manchmal nicht so
frieden schaffe ich doch die wunde
spritzen ist was wollen wir wollen
menschen auf die möglichkeit vorbereitet
und ihnen die chance geben sie zu
gestalten
wenn sich heute lebens möglichkeit
anstalten das sind sehr viele dinge
drinnen und es ist sehr sehr viele die
über den sehr kurzen zeit worden wenn
sie anschauen
diese systeme brauchen heute das heißt
auch mobil preis aus dem jugendstück
computer drin wenn sie sachen lesen wenn
sie sachen schreiben wenn es nahezu
nicht mehr wohnen ihre technologie tun
gleichzeitig ins ungewisse
die alten ansätze sehr positiv
darzustellen der beute
spitze und da glaube ich nur für
mögliche fundamentale genauso damit hat
das internet wird sich massiv was ändern
und das war nicht noch das sich in der
bildung ganz massiv verändern wird
ich weiß dass in deutschland ankommen
also ich habe vorher werde diskussion
auch besser verstehen er hat das super
erdbebenlinie und bildung
ein kollege der sieger vor geworden ist
sicher profitieren alle anderen linken
zurück geschickt davon artikel über den
privaten bildungsmarkt der neben der
schule läuft in singapur ist gigantisch
ich habe jetzt für die chinesischen
kollegen gesprochen und da war der
hinweis 4000 später rechnungen werden
nicht mitdiskutieren
da ist anderen ansatz und ich werde
nachher noch ein bisschen zahlen dazu
kommen das heißt bildung war in der sich
massiv wenn es nach usa gehen
es wird massiv änderungen
wir haben nicht eine gesellschaftliche
entscheidungen wurden können und dies
weniger technologisch dies vermutlich
macht vielen grundlegende bildung
gestaltung die läufer lebenswirklichkeit
gestattet
weil die wenigen möglichkeiten von dem
ab was die leute können über
vorstellungen über was für mich reden
ich bin ein bisschen wackeligen also
informatik ist ein bisschen grundlagen
haben sie gestern auch schon gehört
vielleicht auch ein bisschen das
entzaubern
im hauptteil der mist ist komplett von
13 bis nachts um ihren zu anschauen also
nicht nur schritte zählen
über lesen und dann habe ich jedes jahr
ein
doch die meisten haben das gesehen
ende der neunzigerjahre kaspar liiert
das waren sich die originale mittels
anschauen war ziemlich sauer hatte das
gefühl dass alles nicht so ok hat und
sie habe spreche von computerspielen
besser besser im sinne von tribünen
besser schlafen die menschen heute wird
argumentiert die schlafqualität des
durch ihr spiel ist wesentlich höhere
früher bei gewinn wichtiger und internet
aber deutschen wesentlich besser weil
sie viel bessere trainingsmöglichkeiten
personalisierte trainingsmöglichkeiten
und heute spielt keiner mehr schafft vom
thron zu zeigen dass
über ähnlich übergangs wenige rennen die
hafenpolitik in autos machen wir machen
kannst
das heißt wenn wir den athleten haben
das ist eben eingrenzen lässt dann in
sieben lösungen oder frau uns auch nicht
mehr gehen lassen stellt sondern wir
nutzen die lösungen geben wieder lösen
können
ich habe eine winzige wird es heute
wundert sich und witzig kann man
eingeben welche berufe hat und welche
berufswunsch meine tochter ist ein
komplett vorjahreswerte oder dem so ist
es und ist für mich okay machen
und interessanterweise von den webseiten
das heißt mit zwei kindern die
professoren zum beispiel gibt es welche
die sagen haben prozent
und so verwandelt webseite sein kann man
gar nicht auch mal persönliche
beziehungen kontemplation man sich auch
mal weniger geht es nicht automatisieren
braucht es aber der handel und das ist
so ein bisschen das wir in unserer
estate auf die vorstellungen haben
computern lebensaufgabe weg man kann
zwar von lebensaufgabe nacht über
mögliche folgen gesellschaft in liezen
weniger halt sehr viel zu wenig geld
dabei zu befahren
es gibt ja nicht ob das was in der
diskussion um carney was muss ich haben
muss und gerade im bildungsbereich einig
dass es endlich die richtige sache jetzt
ist auch eine frage wie damit zusammen
dass man den lernen was müssen wir in
köln was in die aufgaben was sind denn
die bereiche wo heute die höchsten ziele
absolventen der tms ist zuvor schlossen
das hast du dir die partie allerdings
nicht alle sind schon weg ist schon
super stau aber nicht andere gruppen
genießen vertrauen
wir sind alle so genannten größte fan
des weines also dass wir leute weiterhin
sind eng mit seinem schaffen die tops
und andy nach dem wert stand ich nach
maß genommen wird
aber nicht nach vorn etwas anders
funktioniert und das ist aus meinen der
ersten bereiche wo die in
digitalisierung oder eben die auffassung
die kg die jobs abschließen und das ist
auch mal geschaut
entweder 300 jahre in denen er die den
kraftmaschinen gerne zuerst streichen
also in dem traditionellen adili trösten
muss vom wahlamt am anfang war das hat
sich gelohnt das ist auch wieder über
sie ohnehin schon ist ein bisschen also
können unbeschränkte sachen machen über
konter beschränken also das ist die
große frage
das hast du mit unsere ideale sind auf
bildungsmessen oder in wollen das lässt
sich ändern ich glaube das ist ganz das
ändern ist aus meiner sicht auch ins
nicht viel widerspruch aber genau
anschauen das künstliche
diese streichen in spanischen marke
würde genauer beim spanier
da hat irgendjemand system über der
agentur die nimmt fußballsport stellen
und generiert heißt nachrichten und das
70.000 nach franziska 92 zu meisterehren
kam auf schreiben kann was das heißt
auch das ist ein kleines teilnehmen das
ernsthafte wissenschaft wie gesagt haben
wir nicht aufpassen zerstört es unsere
gesellschaft und das aber ein etwas
anderes gemeinsame genauer anschaut
es geht um wie verändert sich
kommunikation liefer ändert sich die
form unsere aufmerksamkeit hin zu
bringen was es ist gar nicht so die
super intelligenz besitzen und jetzt
meine frage die sich hier stellt es
werden einige fähigkeiten bringt 50
intelligentes mit ergebnis ist immer zu
lieben was können wir als menschen
was das system
und welche relevanz
[Musik]
ich will gleich die erste frage streiten
und sagen welche menschlichen
fähigkeiten sind trotz künstlicher
intelligenz und intelligente system
essen
doch das ist das wenn wir auch darüber
nachdenken was wir kindern beeindrucken
was besser ist ja das ist richtig dass
wir kriegen und ich komme auf einen
streich timm kurz zurück was tun müssen
dass es nachmittags ist es ein starten
es gibt es also schaffen und das ist in
den disziplinen
sie haben ein team und menschen können
und so geht's
das leben von menschen erlaubt sie
wollen und nicht vielmehr und ich habe
gesagt dass es zu verspannungen
das heißt wir lassen das system und wir
technisch unterstützen die intelligenz
von durchschnitt zugegriffen und das hat
der bundesvorstand was eigentlich wollen
wir solche systeme waren und wir kommen
die unternehmen unserer eigenen
intelligenz zu verstärken und damit
macht man gedankenexperiment und das ein
bisschen zu sein
aktivität nach dem mittagessen bekommen
ständig wittstocker auf zwei minuten und
versuchen sind 243 konkreten sachen aus
zu finden
wirklich die dinge die wir im
berufsleben tun die wir in unserem
alltag können wir besser ohne komisch
welche aufgaben können wir lösen die
karte wieder sagen es ist besser wenn
ich stelle in 26 minuten und dann muss
man parkt information zurück
[Musik]
ja
es kann natürlich jetzt ganz einfach
ein bisschen konkreter sind gibt es
fragen nur der linke fall der bessere
ist berlin mas zum krebs es eigentlich
nicht abstrakt was konkretes wer hat in
seiner probe werden sachen aus gefunden
das bild mit den besten noten
die meisten eine eingekreiste selber
denken
berlin
[Musik]
sein
auf der stelle
demnach liegen die aber werden
derzeitigen einen konstruierten fall wir
haben berichtet
mit salz machen die meisterprüfung im
verschweigen
typisch ist dass die müssen einen oder
zwei tage
die haben beide seiten gedanken
meinungen geben wir geld in die aufgaben
und dem anderen nicht er muss es nicht
benutzt was denn passieren wird
die den zug und da kannst du vorstellen
jetzt einfach modeln und gemüse und die
dem bilder so wird das wird die
kreativität etwas erkläre ich hätte
natürlich immer was aus den plänen
kombinationen und sagen wirklich denkt
seine der kunde muss er mit diskussion
ist es gibt die konferenz in den beinen
als autoritären cognition wo eben der
technische unterstützung weil es
natürlich auch zu führen muss dass
großes thema in reichen nationen ist
immer wieder hier ist ein bisschen
geschwindelt mit sichtbaren sie können
natürlich das gerät als auch die erste
wir können natürlich also sodann der
trick hier ist mit sind wissen was uns
aufhalten kann
die österreichischen dieser eines
hoffentlich vision ihres geschlechtes
entlassen und natürlich sage nach nicht
weg und ich denke das ist ein
interessanter brunnen und dann bin ich
auch ein stück weit drauf wenn man
fragen was müssen wir lernen müssen
lernen zu verstehen man mehr von geräten
haben und man hat und das müssen
trainieren und das geht nur
funktionieren wenn diese geräte haben
die öffentlich tagen
das ist der erste punkt
ich sehe es im größeren kontext der
größte kontext der deutschen gruppe gibt
es nicht
die magischen ganzes stück größer welche
rolle wollen wir als menschen der
gesellschaft zu spielen
die hängen mit wie vernehmen wir unser
geld zusammen und wenn wir uns jetzt
anschauen was macht automatisierung
welche aufgaben er zu uns und das ist
natürlich wenn wir jetzt kinder die die
grundschule gehen werden
ein traum im arbeitsleben lastwagen mit
wenigen bis nicht weiter auch schon wie
das wir sind gewarnt wird als informant
hier schwanken zwischen zehn bis zwanzig
verwendet das sind so die sachen darüber
hinaus es ist sehr schwierig
dabei geht es um rund zwanzig jahre
älteren schwester des toten
dennoch entwickeln und schauen dann ist
die prozesse im interesse unserer
gesellschaft tun die sonst sich
einbringen wie es uns im gesellschaft
gestalten an dem endlich den ersten
punkt dessen lenker war ich ganz kurz
zwei sachen diskutieren
das eine ist das internet ist nicht auf
die richtige das hatten sie gestern
gesprochen so läuft das wasser als
schwache intelligenten seinen
schützlingen und das ist das was er
eigentlich heute
als sehen da gibt es unterschiede ich
mache haben gleich zwei videos etwas
getan hat weil die gelder werden
intelligent sind sie insgesamt sowie der
mensch das ist so was heute auf hin dass
anatomie hinkommen ich haben dann
gesehen zu nehmen und ob ihnen das ist
so oder disziplin die super
intelligentes die uns dann irgendwie in
unseren gleich ganz am ende aus
was wenn man die haben aber das ist ganz
klar im moment ist in berlin dabei wir
haben ein klar definiertes problem wenn
man kann dieses problem haben dann
schaffen das typische weiße eine lösung
zu finden
das feld wird es die hinterlist ist sehr
umfangreichen und ich habe das bild nur
hier aufgelegt um ihn zu sehen
das ist ein ganz großer raum machen im
moment abspielt als in der linse ist so
newsletter zugaben nicht lesen der
mittlere kleine
da ist richtig viel passiert in den
letzten fünf jahren mindestens zehn
jahre ergab sind ungewohnte börse der
welt
da ist nicht viel passiert in den
anderen bedeuten dass es ist nicht
gewöhnlich dass mit der adresse dienste
zu lassen und sind zwei sachen immer
eigentlich besser verstanden haben und
dafür die höchsten klasse die katze
also wir haben alles weiß wie sie haben
bilder ausgewertet und die eigene am
krebs indianern an einfluss und was soll
das jetzt machen sie wohl der funktionen
finden mit der sie schauen rauch und
können sagen dass gehörte der
kreisgruppe oder zur elbe gereist
und im prinzip ist das ist ein bisschen
regen in der mitte stunde landen wir
müssen führen die hier nur wenige
berichten wenn man zu übernehmen und
muss ich die linie durch legen dass ich
jetzt wie die kunden unterhalten die
hier habt und die kreuze überraschend es
geht also wenn jetzt hier etwas nicht
ordentlich machen würdest du sagen linie
hierdurch gesagt dass es halt lieber und
wenn es ein neuer grund kommt dann sehe
ich aber hier kommt welche dann vergesse
ich die linie gesetzt
hier leben und das also das ist nur dass
klassifikationen zu leben das ist es in
zweidimensionalen und das hat mir im
letzten jahren geschafft das tor zu
machen das ist warum ist sprache
erkennen
etwas wie siri funktioniert solches das
ist viel besser geworden das ganze viel
viel besser macht gespült wird
trotzdem haben natürlich das problem
wenn man eben nicht in die daten haben
es auch nicht perfekt was sie hier sehen
macht ihn zu einem perfekten lösung
selbst im krimi menzel raten das andere
also das ist sozusagen die
klassifikation problemen ist es besser
das andere ist das ist sehr sie
verschwinden würden also das heißt wir
lernen aber auch aktionen in der welt
und ist oder erweiterten angesprochen
denn für sie sagte wir können man
beispiel nehmen
sie wollen promoter tischtennis wie
macht man das
wir spielen in baden und der roboter
schlechte zu treten
ok wenn er nicht trifft dann sagen wir
das nicht mit einem anziehen der kamera
für zehn jahre machen
man kann ja
die nummern aus finden was als bewusst
und den regenwald und altersgenossen
ich kann sie ganz toll gespielt und ich
weiß dass gutes verständnis für das
heißt ich habe irgendetwas an seine
intelligenz wie verändert die welt
und dann schauen sie hier also ich schau
dir über die hat sich die welt verändert
und hat sich positiv verändert dass er
hier in tours oder - mit einer wohnung
also ganz eine theorie ist dass ein paar
sätze studium bildungswissenschaften
irgendwo erwähnt sind so ein ganz
einfaches zu verhindern ist das video
hier mit ist und das kann 20 cent mit
tischtennis machen wollen dann brauchst
du da in den ferien zu danken
sie können so etwas macht liebe sachen
muss es sehr wenn daten haben und ich
sehr schnell kreieren können und die
beiden sachen zeigen dass richtig im
fall sind aber gleichzeitig es lösen
probleme lösen sich alle
es löst menschen es ist das nichts neues
dass technologien veränderungen gebracht
haben oder veränderungen bringen und das
bei änderungen des singenden berlin
was wir im letzten jahr gesehen habe wir
haben kommunikation komplett verändert
familien komplett
bekannter ändert über wissen steigern
wir wissen weitergeben
momentan begriff dabei unserer mobilität
zu verändern und was um ihn als einen
der großen bekommt also wieder nach
affen schauen heißt schon passiert dass
ich kenne dich verändert man es anschaut
mobilität wissen mediencenter das
natürlich ganz viele dinge die auch mit
bildung zu tun haben also mobilität
irgendwas entbindung sich im jahr komme
ich an die schule komme ich nicht an die
schule hoffen größe dass ich vielleicht
über technologie mobilität und rücken
kann also ganz ganz ganz viele sachen
die mir rolle spielen aber nicht
zwangsläufig in deutschland und ich
denke das ist das was es schwieriger war
wir müssen wirklich in die welt
bestaunen was anstellt passiert da immer
offen zu schauen was das team und unsere
fahrer
das ist nicht nur im bildungsbereich es
verändert alles und insbesondere sachen
wien erwartungen
das verändert auch die benötigten
fähigkeiten sie brauchen eben nicht mehr
genommen
fähigkeiten die sie gebraucht haben die
sie nicht mit computer geschrieben haben
sie brauchen andere fähigkeiten wenn sie
mit dem textverarbeitungsprogramm
streiten was wenn es mit der hand
steuerlichen es hat sich ganz dem es
zwar keinen nachweis parteien geändert
und das ist was was dich und 20 uhr die
positive wir können jetzt ganz viele die
messe die wir vorher nicht wissen
das heißt so ganz haben wir verwenden
passierte dinge vielleicht zwingend ist
es dann dinge zwischen über nicht so und
was wir in den gesamtkontext sehen das
ist eine großbaustelle
an welchen am anfang des lobes gekommen
oder wir wissen sicher ist auch nicht so
dass das in zwei jahren
wenn sie sich anschauen was wir hier in
bebauung an telefonen haben hat mehr
rechenleistung wie alle betroffenen 100
recht das gewissen der schnellsten
rechner dass die wettersituation
militärischen rechnen sportlerin
wir haben heute in dem raum wesentlich
mehr rechenleistung was sie das handy
dasein abend bis 25 jahren die ganze
welt offen und das wirklich weniger das
heißt das ist das was wir nun sehen dass
google heute in dieser form hat ist
absehbar dass in 25 jahren dabei
das heißt das ist das motto der endung
geschwindigkeit nicht gewinnen und auch
die inhalte die wir generieren
im moment zählt überdies an den inhalten
her
die menge der inhalte in asien generiert
werden ist gigantisch groß und
ganzjährige probleme und fragen
mit der erstellung
unser handeln hat sich mit dem gerät mit
bildung im pharmageschäft haben
was man isst gestellt aber davon ausgeht
dass zehn prozent der leerung
motivierten was vermutlich zu tief
gewesen ist und zeigte ihren lehrern
würden eine buchseite aus als wenn es
dann am tag zeit nehmen und die eine
seite aufarbeiten
vorlesen die seite dazu machen hätte man
das komplette gruppenspiel gegen panama
in dinge tage kommen da ist das problem
kann man nicht macht man natürlich also
die wertvollen müssen mitspielen müssen
grund die das generieren und inhalten
ist nicht mehr den automatik es können
wertungen ähnliche krise so dass ganz
viele der inhalte verfügbar sind und
wenn sie heute schauen die guten schüler
die hamm und den fraglichen willens
und es ist egal ob sie atomkraft wasser
antanzen von investieren szene
entstanden werden sie empfinden zu
informationen
und wir haben mechanismen dass auch die
besten sachen oben ankommen
diese idee dass informationen zu zeigen
nicht verdrücken gibt es nahezu leeren
und den usa kam ich hätte mich auch in
den letzten fünf bis acht jahren haben
sich sehr steigen
weiß jemand wie der deutsche verwendet
sie ist jetzt in deutschland halt machen
wir haben mit denen werden den menschen
das gegründete musiker und es war das
fahren fahren
[Musik]
der mensch hat seinen mehr
dass seine musik macht das studieren hat
manche erklären konnte naja der nacht
noch gezeichnet als auf youtube sind
hatten den ligen tische interessiert das
nicht auf youtube sondern jemanden sagen
erklärt und macht dürfen nicht getan
dass alle winde geschichte öffentlich
gemacht und dann in relativ kurzer zeit
zusammen das heißt jemand hat mir jemand
spielerin was erklärt dass etwas
verkehrtes für andere entsprechendes
nützlichen und inzwischen dass die usa
ein einziges komplette kunden bis zum
ende der high school abgebildet es gibt
aktuell einige projekte dieses internet
neuen scrubs davon haben das heißt ich
kann zum beispiel nicht hochrechnen
dann haben wir das sagen was ich alles
vorher lernen und das ist ehrlich jahren
geschah was wir wissen kommt und dann
wär natürlich nicht unbedingt didaktisch
ausgekommen ist aber zumindest eine
abhängigkeit damit rennen als auch was
wenn ihr sind die wissensinhalte sind
und was wir singen möchte finden am 5
motivierende werden
der schrecken bekommen wir studierende
die nahezu alle inhalte des studiums
sehen werden sie schon angeeignet
am anderen ende haben auch durch die ezb
nicht gesehen haben und ihr umfeld ist
das inzwischen technologie extrem
schnell in die breite geben wenn es
anschauen bereit hilfen zu
die mühe ist nach 15 jahren mit right
von monster dienstag auf 300 jahre und
wenn ich meine es auch in der schule
gesehen hab ich doch was ist dies nicht
mehr vorstellen immer vor jahren
vorgemacht hat für frust folgte
natürlich vom - macht der bundesländer
eine stunde aber sie schauen die
organisation leute verwenden die
infrastruktur ist und dass es in zwanzig
jahre dauert
das gilt erst recht schnell dass sich
infrastruktur ist setzen
und wenn jemand eine andere
infrastruktur anbieten die schlechte ist
die weniger wenn du weißt dass sie etwas
mit glauben wissen was ich mir von den
jobs verwendet habe man dann eben dazu
die klaus t
an hunden juni ist eine wesentlich
bequemer mir das andere was passt ihr
die leute nehmen das dass frieden
arbeiten und hier ist mein punkt des
verwirklichen
inzwischen sind viele der personen in
den schulen in bildungseinrichtung
digitaltechnik
nicht immer steht für organisation für
kommunikation und nicht nur für den
tipps und so wird schon jetzt hier
unterrichten auch deutsch
obwohl die kinder ja auch deutsch können
dass also die ideen des trainers
brauchen das nicht unterrichten das ist
so ein bisschen in die falsche ecke und
schon ein wichtiger punkt den wir bisher
haben - reichlich basis wer keine ziele
hat dann scheitern und das ist im moment
ist und es kann nicht sein
wir möchten 20 das ist im moment der
punkt wo wir ganz häufig sind es ziel
ist was anzuschaffen
aber es ist nicht klar was das ziel ist
damit zu tun und sind kann man jederzeit
ändern
nur wenn ich anfangen keine ziel war gar
nicht klar sein dass es damit scheitern
wird
ich bin jetzt ganz kurze sind office
bereiche nicht darum wer also
insbesondere im asiatischen bereich im
moment sehr stark angeschaut hat und er
weiß ich wer behandelt wird oder an
spitzentagen normal das ist das große
thema hat man auch haben schon gesagt
den tausenden demonstrieren was ist das
genau war in einen kollegen gestellt
haben und die forschung kommt von
kollegen aus so prominente
zusammenarbeiten
die haben sich angeschaut ich habe eben
eine brille
ich habe sozusagen der nach findest
rechtswesen und der kunde ist also tief
einfach beschließen die sagen je mehr
wie man liest desto höher
einfach den kooperation zwischen lingen
gelesen was macht der beste was macht
die besorgten eltern und kinder fürs
lesen
das heißt wir und das war zuerst im
forschungs projekt inzwischen gibt es
auch eine japanische firma kienzle hat
mit brille
dies und die sie ganz nett aus was ist
eingebaut und jetzt kann man eben sagen
gewesen und waren sie ihr mann gas oder
war es anders spielen viel text man kann
sich nur mitlaufen augen machen was wir
uns anschauen sich sehr starken
operativen belastungen also lernen die
zelle auf einem guten also sind diese
gespräche zu wenig angestrengt dass wir
so weiter gemacht aber anschauen kann
viele arbeiten die leute hinten klo oder
als in serie hinterlassen dass ich über
das meer andere arbeit und das mit einer
wärmebildkamera von komiker auf die man
auf und wer sich nicht anstrengt dann
kann man das sehen
es war noch ein gedankenexperiment noch
mal für zwei jahren bin ich auch schon
fast am ende
das sind sachen die sind technisch
möglich viele der unternehmen die polen
nicht sagen das sind 60 möglich die
frage ist das entweder was machen wir
hier in gedanken experiment bearbeitet
dass man selbst schon gemacht seine
eltern antworten
geht es nach den willen gezeigt ein
alles auf was sie jede lösung das
gesehen haben ist ein bisschen
schwieriger bei menschen einfach denkt
man und es weiß wasser können also nicht
können so was kann man über twitter
facebook das alles andere denn die
prozent bis gelesen und sie kennen ist
nicht das was wir wissen können was
nicht können und wir können jetzt noch
mal machen personalisieren also zusammen
gesehen
sie kriegen die webseite und die
webseite wenn schwierige wörter die ezb
noch ganz viel schwieriger wird
automatisch mit weiteren ersetzen
synonym musiker seit beginn auf die mode
für sie ist vielleicht gerade den kunden
dass wir ein bisschen zu wissen dass ich
jedes mal auch was werden lassen
wir stellen wollen kriegen wir das auch
nicht mal zwei minuten ist das sozusagen
ist es mit zu kunden lieber teuren
baldmöglichst oder ist es eher was
wasser vermeiden
ich glaube alles wiederum was ist los
[Musik]
sein
ok
[Musik]
hat jemand was rohrs kontron
sie ist
immer diese sein
das ist extrem bitter
[Musik]
16 tel
zusätzlich vermehrten die bibel ist
ausgeschieden
geissen zu kombinieren
bis hin zu kriegen als rss feed
es geht mir um
es ist interessant gar nicht suchen
wie sehen sie das
auch mal was für die maschine lösen
den ganzen tag
[Musik]
also auf das
was unsere anderen zusammen und das
hier werden
was das ist also hoch
[Musik]
dass sie gesagt haben eine antwort zum
modus nachmittäglichen kann ich wieder
vollständig das neue
das ist ein problem ist
also ist natürlich bewusst gemacht und
ich habe ein anderes zeichen ein
natürlich 19 geschnitten gewaschen und
machen das was jemand gesagt hat das war
was in deutschland passiert hat die
bisher untersuchten das in anderen
bereichen der welt passiert halte ich
für nicht ausgeschlossen
und dann kommen eben die frage
wir haben ganz der globalisierung ein
und ich denke dass in deutschland immer
die frage ist welches immer wenn wir
denn zumindest nur teilaspekte brauchen
dann möchten wir dass das ist bitter
weil wir haben ihnen passt das
klassische dass man weiß dass jantzen
wie meine mutter war dann das ist echt
nicht gut dann sind die anderen
schneller gewachsen und dann haben wir
in deutschland wieder ein rechtsfuß in
unserem besten was ist auch wieder ganz
interessant zu sein
wir sind sehr skeptisch bis es an
irgendjemand anders gemacht hat deshalb
ist die meinung dass solche saftig
ignoriert bis zu versuchen sie zu
verstehen und alternativen dazu brauchen
zu überlegen was die alternative und die
idee ist genauso gemacht wie das früher
gemacht hat ist eben nichts die beste
alternative mit der markt bestehen wird
ich hoffe dass ein größten produkten
ein querschnitt also das kennt er sich
mit gregor links gehört recherche sehr
wichtig denn der student muss der rat
und wir sind es an der uni ich kann zum
beispiel bestimmte formate gar nicht
anbieten weil ich in prüfungen nicht
nach systemen abhängig und dann baut
sich irgendwelchen gründen um das
14fache
das heißt ich habe das was erwähnten
arbeiten großbritannien
es war einfach zu heiß und ich wollte
noch was zu essen
die küche beim kochen und dann war es
das thema mission geschafft
30 jährigen geschichte von ersten auf
und getränke
das heißt der band ihren lieben uns
irgendwie in dem 1
was wir tun und damit kommen wieder auf
den punkt zurück westen und im moment
ist es eben das haben wir vorher in
einem der vorträge instagram versucht es
möglichst so zu halten dass er nicht
ausgehen wessen besitz des möglichst
google und daher versuchen drin zu
halten das heißt wir sind ganz
ich mit beteiligen sondern es während
der schlächter in rust anschluss eines
der acht deutschen pass und das heißt
ich bin jetzt auf meiner vollsten ende
bringen
vielleicht ist die frage das ist was die
oecd veröffentlicht hat und das ist der
anteil der wissenschaftlichen abzuwenden
das welche informationen im technischen
teil in den stämmen soundchecks also die
leute die typischerweise auch so eine
infrastruktur und dann technisch
brauchen also ist auch informatiker
werden
das gericht
studieren das heißt wer bei uns die
malstunden wer bestimmt wieder
kommuniziert und was dass es 20 30
die aussage ist 37 prozent der
absolventen in einem der stent welcher
universität gefunden chinesischen
realität kunden
und 26 deutschland ist vorbei
hier und da hat man gesagt man es recht
anstrengend ganz viel werbung machen
noch 16 das heißt einige der sachen wird
uns abgenommen aber ich will mit einer
positiven folien in der schule der nicht
ausgebuhte gründe aber einen
kontroversen projekt angefangen hat wir
schauen ob wir nicht einfach mit
digitalen technologien lernten
versetzen und die fan mehr hängen diese
vorträge auch im englischen sachen haben
können was hätte unsere technologie
gegeben
das büro und im raum wissen unter
ähnlichen der intellektuellen qualität
hin dass das vortragen wie auch die
diskussion führen damit angefangen
abschließend
ein
natürlich ist
hier
das sind
bald ist das
ich glaube das ganze land machen ferien
packen also das ist jetzt sind also gab
es verschiedene wellen ist jedes mal
besser geworden
ob es dieses mal gut genug weiß ich dass
ich bin ich überzeugt dass es 20 punkten
und ist aber ich würde auf jeden fall
denken es ist klar was krieg wagen sind
was die
nochmal 20
weniger ob es nicht sein sollte
und es ist eben also es gibt sehr viele
indikatoren die sagen dass ein nächsten
20 jahren wird das passieren
es gibt keine wirklich sagen weitere
mieter des jahrhunderts wird es für
jemand also wenn man test machen können
über das ist in der realität oder nicht
und es gibt nur durch sozusagen nämlich
floren von sachen passieren dass man
wirklich was schenke ich bin nicht nur
das gekauft
das ist natürlich dann nochmal eine
sache dass wir uns in einer ganz anderen
vielleicht auch in mehreren
gleichzeitig aufhalten was wir
eigentlich nicht
neben verschiedenen